what's up everybody is a community so I
was recently at the World Championships
they were selling new seller Germany I
was invited there by the International
Date of consideration the IDDM wanted me
to make some trick shot videos with some
of the world's best players at the World
Championships so well I went there and
it's great that feeling with these
players there are different videos to
not be really nice as actually now made
a population of the defense missions
will be on there and it's really nice
and I'll show it to you now hope you
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
so that was the video he was a lot of
fun making and let me know the comments
below description do you think was the
best one I still have to say about the
everything sells devote sufficient
notice absolutely amazing event like
everything was so well organized there
and that the way you they are looks
incredible
I actually have a picture to show you
here's our supplies different size there
were four tables in the main floor and
there were these four 7,000 or 8,000
people and the atmosphere in the hall
was awesome especially during the last
three or four days when he was
completely sold out as you might know
eventually most of the middle swing to
the Chinese where the women team of we
so de we heard their World Championship
title
meanwhile in domésticos along to his
second World Championship final here's
actually share with Milan after the
exhausting fight but at least unable to
feel nutritious with him
but maybe sometime in future without
will be but they are being as devotion
issues not watching some people this
players compete there and also feel some
videos with them afterwards an
incredible experience not just once a
huge thanks to the idea for making that
all possible but as if this was all for
this week's video if you enjoyed it
please leave a thumbs up below and make
sure to try Billy channel if you haven't
already
until next time
you